this video I want to talk about the dark
reactions of photosynthesis which is
basically the Calvin cycle which is
involved in carbon fixation so where
does this part of photosynthesis
actually occur this occurs if you recall
in the stroma of the chloroplast so what
we're doing is we're taking carbon
dioxide and fixing it right we're fixing
it into making making glucose
essentially so we said in a previous
video that although that the treatment
that the dark reaction is light
independence the dark reaction can occur
in the dark so even though it's light
independent it does depend on the light
reaction to a certain extent why is that
the reason why is because it uses ATP
right and NADPH oops
NADPH from the light reaction so the
light reaction creates an eight NADPH
and ATP that the dark reaction can use
so during the day a plant will go
through the light reaction create a
bunch of ATP and NADPH and at night when
there's no light the dark reaction can
occur so the dark reaction can occur
during the day as well but at night the
light reaction can occur only dark
reaction can so if you had a plant
though in the dark all the time would it
be able to survive the answer is no
because it would need a source of ATP
and NADPH however if it was in the dark
and you somehow found a way to supply
with ATP and NADPH without having the
light around then the plant could exist
in the dark and it could live in the
dark okay so the overall reaction of of
the the calvin cycle we start off with
six carbon dioxides and we're going to
invest twelve NADPH ah's and eighteen
ATP and then we're going to get out of
this
twelve of those in 18 of those 18 Billis
okay so now what is the actual Calvin
cycle look like well the point of its to
make glucose okay there are three stages
there the first stage being carbon
fixation the second stage being two
twofold al phosphorylation step in a
reduction state step and then the third
and final stage is the regeneration of
the five carbon acceptor so what I want
you to keep in mind in order to
understand this as best you can
I've written out this key here so in
orange I'll be putting little numbers
that indicate the number of however many
molecules there are of that particular
molecule anything in green will indicate
the number of carbons in that molecule
and the number of carbons in purple that
are boxed that will be the total number
of carbons present okay which will
basically be this number of times this
number okay
so what are we starting off with we're
starting off with this thing called rib
elos one five bisphosphate and we're
starting off with six of them
Reba Lowe's you might recall sounds a
lot like ribose ribose had five carbons
with a five carbon sugar rib you Lowe's
is also a five carbon sugar so we have
rib ulos one five bisphosphate so this
thing has two phosphates on and it's
five carbons long okay so if we have six
of them we have six tribulus 1 5 bits
phosphates and each one is 5 carbons
long how many total carbons do we have
we have 30 so the reason I'm doing this
is because it's it's very easy to get
lost in this if you don't keep track of
your carbons okay so at this stage we
have six rib ulis one five bisphosphate
that in each one has five carbons we
have a total of 30 carbons so this first
stage is the carbon fixation stage so in
this stage what we're going to do is
we're going to add carbon dioxide's we
want to add one carbon dioxide to each
one of these ruby lows one five
bisphosphate so we're going to have to
add six of them okay and each
each carbon dioxide is of course just
one carbon so that's a total there of
six carbons right so if we're adding six
carbons here then we should have 36
carbons total in the next step so if
we're having these these six carbon
dioxides each one is being added to
every last one five bisphosphate we
would create six six carbon molecules
for a total of 36 carbons but that that
six carbon molecule is very very
unstable and it actually splits up into
three carbon molecules okay which is 3
phosphoglycerate so 3 phosphoglycerate
you've probably already seen it before
you should have seen it already in
glycolysis gluconeogenesis it's a three
carbon molecule with one phosphate group
so if this is a three carbon molecule
and we have 36 carbons at this point how
many of them do we have with 36 carbons
so we have we should have 12 of these
three phosphoglycerates okay so we put
these two together the carbon fixation
stayed then we made 12 3
phosphoglycerates once we have three
phosphoglycerates
we're going to turn them into 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate but what was the
enzyme that created 3 phosphoglycerate
from these these two things here this
enzyme is called Rubisco Rubisco is
basically Ribble owes 1/5 bisphosphate
carboxylase oxygenase okay so that's the
enzyme that catalyzes this carbon
fixation stage so now once we have this
3 phosphoglycerate this three carbon
molecule there's 12 of them 36 total
carbons what we're going to do is we
want to turn it into 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate now 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate again we've seen
this in glycolysis in gluconeogenesis
this molecule has three carbons as well
and you should already be familiar with
this structure but now it has but it's a
bisphosphoglycerate these are 3
phosphoglycerate is just one phosphate
on each one of these things now we have
two phosphates so we must have added a
phosphate for every single one since we
didn't change we still
have 36 carbons and since we didn't
change number of carbons we should still
have 12 of these right 12 times 3 will
equal 36 now each one of these things
must have had must have added a
phosphate right that's the
phosphorylation state step of the second
stage so where do those phosphates come
from they come from ATP
how many ATP's did we use up well we
needed to add one ATP for each one of
these 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate so we must
have added 12 ATP so after we've added
those 12 ATP we have now 12 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate so once we have this
1 3 bisphosphoglycerate we want to turn
it into the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
you might recall that this step and this
step in this order are from
gluconeogenesis so now going from here
to here what would normally happen this
would be first of all it's gonna be the
reductions the second part of the
seconds of the stage so we would need a
reducing agent in gluconeogenesis
it was NADH but in this case we're
actually going to use NADPH so we are
actually going to add 12 NADPH is here
right one for each one of these 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate
and that's going to we're going to end
up getting 12 nadp+ ha's and of course
we're going to get 12 glyceraldehyde 3
phosphates and the phosphates from this
from these bisphosphoglycerate 12 of
them will hop off as inorganic
phosphates so what are we at now at the
second stage of the cycle we
phosphorylated and reduced the sugars
and now we have glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and which is a three carbon
molecule we have 12 of them so that's 36
total carbons still so now what happens
here at this point two of these
glyceraldehyde 3 phosphates are going to
leave and 10 of them will continue on in
the cycle now again of course each one
of them is still just 3 carbons long but
now how many carbons stay here
well if there's ten of them there's ten
ten g3ps and each one is three carbons
long then we have 30 carbon staying in
the cycle and then that must mean six of
them left to G three P's to three carbon
molecules six carbons what are these two
three g3ps do these make glucose right
they leave to make glucose via
gluconeogenesis right one of these g3ps
will be converted into dihydroxyacetone
phosphate and then we'll go all the way
back to glucose so these 30 carbons here
they send g3ps what they're going to do
is they're going to go back to making
they're going to go back and become six
rouble s15 bisphosphate does that make
sense
well if we have 30 carbons here 30
carbons here we don't need to add or
remove any carbons all we need to do is
make sure that we add phosphate groups
right because we're going to have these
which run out of three phosphates only
have one phosphate these are regular one
five bits phosphates have two so we need
to add one phosphate for each one that
we create for creating six of them we
need to add six ATP's right so this this
is the third and final stage which is
the regeneration of the five carbon
except the 5 carbon of sec acceptor of
course is rebill s15 bisphosphate so
then once we create these once we've
regenerated the 5 carbon acceptor we can
begin another cycle of the calvin cycle
so I hope that was helpful and thanks
for watching